are coveted lockdowns in china deterring
women there from having children well
that's the growing concern amongst
demographers as beijing struggles with
already slowing birth rates
new reporting from reuters citing
regional statistics and speaking with
experts as well as with young women
suggests the harsh lockdowns of recent
months are taking a toll fewer children
are being born
beijing already expected its population
to begin shrinking in the coming years a
recent u.n report predicts india will
take over its title of most populous
nation in 2023
earlier i spoke with our correspondent
in taipei zachary lee and asked why
china's zero coveted lockdowns were
hitting the country's already declining
birth rate
well stephen exactly some studies have
already shown that pandemic and economic
uncertainty weigh on birth rates around
the world historically and as we all
know china's zero covet policy affects
society drastically for example many
women are in difficulties in carrying in
a pregnancy and taking care of an infant
under heavy restrictions let alone many
are facing financial and secure
insecurity and worries about love
coveted vaccines affecting babies etc
you know some chinese young people told
the media that this zero covet policy
which is imposing strict controls on
people's lives whenever there are
positive cases may have caused profound
damage to their desire to have children
so some demographers say that chinese
people feel of losing control of their
lives and this is one of the reasons
that they choose to not have babies all
right so the financial reasons the
feeling of a loss of control you just
mentioned there zach how significant is
this however for china as a society when
we look at falling demographics
well stephen you have to understand that
we all know the fact that china's past
economic growth was supported by its
population bonus you know this is like
the huge working age population so a
spoiling birth rate would probably have
an impact on china's economic growth
also you know in the future as the
decline in the country's fraternity rate
and the aging of its population become
more pronounced some negative effects
were also foreseeable for example you
know the the communist party leadership
will continue to age and it probably
will affect the whole society in china
since we all know that the greater the
proportion of young people in the
society the more dynamic it is
we've seen recently that beijing is
trying to make it more attractive
to have families to have larger families
is it likely to be successful in this
can it really do something about this
trend
well you know chinese the chinese
government is actually facing a lot of
problems for example the zero-covet
policy and also you know the high
property prices and rising education
costs those are the problems that the
chinese government needs to deal with
you know the chinese government now they
met let's make they have made a lot much
effort to encourage families to have
more children and announced in 2015 that
it would allow married couples to have
two children but after a brief outbreak
in 2016 the national birth rate has been
falling year on year same as like this
year or probably next year prompting the
chinese
authorities to further losing the policy
to three children last year well also
you know in the low four decades you
know the local governments in china
forced millions of women to abort
pregnancy deemed
illegal by the state and the least one
child policy but now they are actually
giving slogans a policy to encourage
more births you know the common
incentives we know
include cash hangouts also real estate
subsidies and also extension of
maternity leave